[Music]
congratulations thank you
do you want to start by telling us
kind of how you guys met and how how the
project came to be
danielle
morrissey and our daughter stephanie
jessica whatever you should really talk
to her you know no it's just a job
my mom is so sorry for your loss
no funny business with maya thank you i
think everyone that's bi is
experimenting you have zero gaydar
excuse me kid i lived through new york
in the 80s my gaydar is strong as a boy
[Music]
it's based off a short film um and it
was my final project in film school and
i met rachel
um at the audition for it in a dorm
basement
and i'd seen her in a bunch of sketches
and
other student films and then later
learned that you were like skipping
class in order to like meet every film
student you could to like make all the
connections you could um
and
yeah and then we did the short and it
went really well and rachel is super
ambitious and goal driven and organized
and
she's we're going to say i'm a virgo
she's a virgo um and everyone's like oh
okay
uh and i think yeah with rachel's like
structuring of like how are we gonna
make this once i said i wanted to make
it she was like how and when and what
are your weekly goals and let's take out
your planner and figure this out for you
um
so yeah that that's how we met and
especially for for jews i feel like they
go two ways they're either like i'm a
mess but i'm creative or i'm like going
to get this done
and i'm like not as creative you feel
like more of like the messy creative
rachel's great
um i am a mess no i'm not organized at
all um
no rachel still reviews my goals um
because she has one year three year and
five year goals and you used to carry
them around with you in your backpack
yeah you used to always have them
printed yes um but now you live in lace
you don't run around
i don't go anywhere i stay in my house
yeah where do the goals go
they're just they sit on my my tight my
table i said tables so weird but they
sit on my table
yeah interesting you you brought up that
you're a virgo yes
is the character a virgo
no
i don't think so i wrote what it was at
one point we wrote it down but she's
definitely not a virgo
um
she's probably like i'm like would she
be like
she's like a scorpio yeah
yeah manipulative right
scorpio scorpios famously hate me so
like i have personal beef with scorpios
okay maybe she's a libra or something or
something she's not a libra but i'm like
but i think scorpio yeah sorry yeah i
wonder if we would get along
um
so i i knew rachel previously i didn't
know emma um
and then watching the film i felt like
i saw parts of you rachel
and then
i felt even not knowing you
parts of you
is that like how how where did
you
start and the character end and where
did rachel what did rachel bring to the
character that you might not have in
your life
and so on yeah that's a that's a good
question because i think it evolved from
the short to the future um because we
talked about when i made this short i
feel like i really related to danielle
and was sort of going through everything
she was and then
for the two years in between the
shortened feature
you know our our path sort of went like
this where i sort of like mellowed out
and you know didn't have that experience
and had some perspective and was trying
to write about it and rachel
unfortunately had to go through her own
version of of danielle's like you know
yeah everybody's you know yeah
you know like a nervous breakdown in a
day but it was it was more drawn out it
was more drawn out it was like a nervous
breakdown every day for like a year yes
for two years um so i think i i mean i
think rachel brought so much comedy to
the short and improvised so much and
just gave it a lot more like lightness
and i think originally it was still
going to be like a dramedy but i i think
transparent was like my big reference
and i think it was going to be darker um
and and somehow rachel was just able to
make it so funny and yet so grounded so
i feel like it ended up being
quite a combo of the two of us but once
it was in your hands i remember i was
trying to like revisit my old self and
listen to the same music like trying to
get me in the zone but it was like
really like traumatizing me to like
bring all that old stuff back and rachel
was like i you know
i am an actor and uh
i will do the trauma you're like i'm
experiencing it right now
hand it to me and i'll do it um so yeah
yeah
cool
um i was like trying to think about
themes in the movie and i think you have
a really distinct
universe i mean so far as a filmmaker i
know this is your first feature so
you'll continue to expand on like
what your thing is as you continue to
move forward but
um it almost had it had such a
specific um thing for me that set out
like in a nancy meyer's universe it's
like the white woman in the kitchens
it's like she lives so solidly in that
universe
and in the emma seligman universe
no one
trusts each other
like that stood out in a big way for me
i'm like every character is is
distrustful of every other character and
you kind of like see it
in each scene and like you don't know
that they know exactly what's wrong but
everyone knows that something is wrong
would you do is that would you agree
with my analysis
i think that i just wrote from
my perspective and so i didn't think
about it in terms of who's trusting who
but um
i think that
so often in chaotic families everybody
means well but everybody's trying to get
in there and and is quite stressed about
something
maybe they don't need to be stressed
about but um i definitely wanted like
because it was a small space and one day
i was looking for as much irony as
possible so
the
more characters that could know
something about one character but we
know the other characters don't know
that person knows something the the
better i thought um so i think that's
where a lot of sort of the like mistrust
came from because it was sort of all
about hiding different things
mostly rachel hiding different things
but then
from different things for different
people and then once someone knows
something then they can't know so i feel
like that's where
that kind of stuff came from but i don't
know how many people like trust
everybody in their family like i is yeah
normal like people trust people like i i
yeah i guess i've never thought about it
yeah people you know some people are
more trusting than others i think but i
think it's you know it's uh a good
coping mechanism to be discerning with
the people
around you maybe we'll call it
discernment discernment yeah but i found
it captivating i was like
you know who knows what like it's it's
good storytelling in the way that like
you know
that he knows what she knows or what
she's told him and he doesn't know what
she hasn't told him but then there's
this other layer of it that's like
any anybody could be
lying to anyone
is it like is that like a family thing
for you or like
let me transition the question to the
family actually
like
because i think
if
if you were my daughter
and i watched this i'd be like she
[ __ ] hates me
um so was your family receptive did it
make them think did it make them like
no uh no they were
no they're they disowned me no my
they're super super supportive um i
think that the the distrust or the lying
i think that all just comes from
insecurities and so i feel like every
character
in this um
has their own insecurities and often i
feel like when you're at any sort of big
social event but often at least in my
family because we have such a huge
extended family with a lot of
accomplished people in them
you're trying to perform so much and i
think danielle is and her mom is like
maybe the only character that's not as
her dad but
um no my parents are super supportive
they my dad was in the short film he
played the dad he played fred's role and
then um
he had a line in the movie he he was the
guy who had to use the bathroom that was
my dad
so no they're they're uh
they're a window open or an air
freshener is that what he says a fan a
fan a fan
there's a lot of a lot of people have to
like go to the bathroom in the movie
is that from personal experience
i think bathrooms can be an escape in
this kind of thing i don't know there
was really nowhere these characters
could go so i was like who can go to the
bathroom who needs the cigarette like we
just need to move through because people
are just eating and talking and standing
around and it's not that exciting um
visually so yeah there's a lot of
bathroom time i also feel like the
bathroom
is like what you said an escape and i
feel like any time i'm like at a place
and i'm like in the bathroom but i'm
like who am i like it's so it's like
you're at a bar you're having fun with
your friends and you're like in the
mirror and you're like do you believe in
god like
it just goes there so quickly and i feel
like every time i was like in the
bathroom it's like that was like the
most intense scenes i was like you're
having a panic attack
and it's like you have to go to the
bathroom to do that
yeah
yeah
um
you brought up god
um
which i i
i found i find this in a lot of
jewish work and jewish people that this
is a very jewish movie
i would say
you would agree um
uh and there's very very little talk
about god
and the one time she kind of goes to
religion or goes to god is when she's
like at wit's end when she starts
kissing the the uh what do you call it
torah yeah
i'm jewish um
but it's it's almost uh as like a last
case scenario like nothing has worked
let me
turn to religion now which is the whole
the whole reason that they're there is
because of religion but none of the old
people are talking about god or religion
no one's like bringing it up so yeah can
you talk about your
relationship to i guess judaism and
religion and like how you incorporated
it into the film
yeah for sure um i grew up in a super
reformed community so you know we never
talked about god but
um and i feel like people in my family
don't even believe in god some of them
um but
uh i have a huge you know
well just kidding you know
uh
i'm gonna skip that but uh
i uh i think you know we had a really
big extended family in a really big
community so at least in toronto um
i'm a fourth generation toronto
ashkenazi jew so like all my family
members are there and
cousins and cousins and cousins so every
time we meet up it's for a holiday or
for a bat mitzvah or for a bris or a
wedding and or a funeral or shiva um
so
you just go to these things and it's
tradition and you wouldn't even think
twice about like of course your kid is
gonna have a bar mitzvah and of course
you're gonna have a jewish wedding in
all of the ways and invite all of your
cousins and
things like that so that's just the way
i grew up and i think as i've gotten
older i've like tried to figure out
the spiritual stuff which my parents
find weird
um they're like it's so interesting that
you're like
interested in exploring like jewish
stuff in like your movies and i'm like
we had the most jewish upbringing ever
like why is that weird yeah but they
they wanted to remain cultural in a way
yes yeah i think a lot of
a lot of jews are secular it's like i
went to this uh
jewish
thing retreat and i remember there was
probably like 60 people there and they
like asked who believed in god there
were like two people there i was like
everyone here identifies as jewish but
only two people believe
in god it was just interesting to me
and i you know i think it's also
interesting in the film that like i mean
every even the smallest characters are
like projecting so much on to everyone
else like all the old women talking
about her weight and everything else
like and they're not even really
thinking about
that you don't even really do you ever
know who died or how she died
her name is oh no i don't we don't know
her name no but but we know that's zelda
abby abby's
um
uh the the woman who uh silda as the
actress she plays like the host of the
shiva yeah we know it's her mom yeah
maybe the audience doesn't know but we
we knew that silda definitely knows i
think
she got into character that's like a
cool
comment on like the narcissism of
everyone in the film in a way that you
never no one's talking about the dead
girl you know woman old lady
uh yeah that was
that was interesting
um
i don't have a question based on that
but we can go to another question uh do
you want to talk about
uh
projecting and projecting or like where
yeah like where you came to the
character like things that you
found in her maybe things you learned
about yourself through
portraying her
yeah well i feel like i got like a very
rare experience which is like doing the
short and then doing the future two
years later after like
two really like difficult years of my
life that like what emma was saying like
i felt like i was like kind of learning
the lessons that danielle learns in like
the course of a day
and i think i was able to find my way in
through like anxiety i'm like a very
anxious person
um but i think i project my anxiety like
outwards kind of like a like are you mad
like danielle would never like check in
she's like this
bagel is good
um like do you know what i mean like i
think so it was kind of like me being
like what are similarities and what are
our differences and how the like
feelings that we have project our words
and like
emma's such an amazing writer and
director and like she kind of helped me
chart this
basically like this path for danielle
where it's like
in every scene it's like one like what
level of anxiety is she at because it's
like
it can't all be the same thing and so
sometimes she'll be like it's a ten okay
down to a six now four and an eight
again
um
and like that was really helpful and
then we also talked about like who has
power in each scene because there's so
much shifting power between like
danielle and max and maya
and like
the adults and everyone um and i feel
like as a young woman you're just which
is something i really really do you want
power and control and it feels like it's
so often like ripped away from you or
you think you have it and you don't
um and so i think that was really
helpful as well
cool
nice um
me going i you i'm reaching for control
but like you know what i mean where
you're like you think you're like
standing on the ground and then it's
like and you're like
never mind yeah i mean to me the
character was like wanted
something
so badly wanted some like ground to walk
on but like didn't had no concept of
like what really she wanted or how to
get it
um which i think
is something super relatable especially
for the age she's around like what 24 or
25.
that whole range though yeah yeah
yeah
but yeah i felt i definitely like felt
for her because i'm like
you want this thing
it's not there you have nowhere to grasp
for so you're just grasping at
you know
sex at
you know relationship said money at
family
and like nothing is
really working
um
yeah
glad you're related but also
yeah anytime anyone says they were late
i'm like thank you but also like sorry
sorry yeah
um
no it's cool i mean like it's definitely
it it was a
for me it's a it was a tough tough movie
to watch like it's funny obviously and
you're so funny and the actors are all
really funny but it's a
it's it's a tough one to to sit through
at times i was thinking like also i want
to talk about the score but like i think
the score has a lot to do with the
tension of it i also think that if you
ever do like a dvd release you should do
a version with just the kirby enthusiasm
music
i think like the movie could work on
like just a completely different level
it's like i know you cheated
anyway um yeah so talk about like
did you have did you have the concept
for
the score and the tension you wanted it
to hold before
going into shooting or was that did that
come after
i didn't well that's a great idea so i
appreciate it um i've never worked with
music at all before so i wasn't
picturing a score at all i wanted to try
to like just go for something super you
know realistic and and not making the
audience like reminding them that
they're in a movie by playing music um
and
i wanted to sort of feel like a fly on
the wall and then when we were shooting
the scene where rachel is looking at the
baby
and the baby's like crying and we're
getting a real like look at
i i want him
edgar was the actor even though he's
playing a girl but we're getting a real
good look at the baby for the first time
i realized that all the dialogue that
i'd written with all the women around
rachel asking her like what she's doing
with her life i just realized all of
that was going to be background noise
and that what's really happening is
between her and the baby and that i was
going to need something to like
communicate that um and so then that's
when i decided i want to score but i
wasn't sure what i wanted until we got
to that stage
in post
and then i
wanted something i decided i want
something like string based because i
wanted it to kind of be like klezmer
inspired um and then i just kept saying
the ariel uh ariel marcus are incredible
composer i just kept saying i wanted to
be stressful just just stressful
stressful stressful and then eventually
you know she was like this is kind of
like a horror score what you're asking
me for um and and we just sort of like
went with it but i was just worried that
people weren't going to understand like
what danielle was feeling because
she rarely gets the opportunity to talk
about it with anybody and there's so
many other characters talking and so
much going on and i just wanted to make
sure we were like in her head and nobody
else's yeah i feel like it really really
punctuated also
that baby
loki
kind of the mom was right
that baby's kind of ugly
right
i just i was just like when i first saw
the baby i was like
not no
oh my god did you know that baby
we know that we know the baby so we
can't it'll grow usually ugly babies
grow up to be really hot but like
that
he seems really smart
he
he and his mom did us a huge favor
because we didn't everyone who's working
on the movie was like 23 and we were
like does anyone know someone with a
baby like who can find us a baby on the
street um and so it was like our
producers katie's friend or old
co-worker her baby and
he was cr i just feel so bad he was in
that hot van at the end and and dude we
didn't we had the no the baby was not
harmed but it was great he was fine yeah
they were just pinching him really hard
literally what happened was diana was
like carrying edgar around for honestly
like four hours in stiletto heels like
cooing to the baby being like we just
have to connect i was like i cannot hold
the baby she was like we just have to
connect she's like
the most beautiful voice i've ever heard
because he couldn't stop crying and he
wasn't supposed to cry at all in the
script yeah and then he was and then
there was one scene where we needed him
not to and
diana was like it's the mom we i need to
be with him alone away from the mom and
you're right she was like we have to
connect we need to connect
and then what happened was like on the
last day the mom revealed like if
everyone kind of like sings wheels on
the bus like everyone he's like kind of
in trance and so then it's like the
whole crew the whole cast like right
before the take being like wheels on the
bus
very like quiet and honestly chilling
and then like it's like the last person
like fades out action like so quiet and
then we got at least one take where he
didn't cry but it was that that was the
that was really hard i thought it added
the crying added so much to especially
the end it's like shut the [ __ ] up
there's nothing worse than like a baby's
cry it's like why do they do that you
know what i mean
that's what i was thinking but
i did feel like it added so much to
to what everyone was was feeling inside
because it does end on a
you know it ends on a sweet moment with
with the the two people connecting but
like everyone else is pretty unsettled
and i i
i felt like the i thought it was
intentional so good on good on that ugly
baby
i'm gonna stop calling the baby ugly um
it's a beautiful baby children are great
it worked i was gonna say i was on when
we were when we were coming back from
new york there was a baby crying on my
plane and the mom was like stop you're
being ridiculous and it's like a newborn
and i was like that is how i felt like
it is you're like cut seriously enough
shut up
so it's interesting because i think it
does like it like triggers danielle in a
whole other way there's no way to be
like i'm just not gonna look at the baby
it's like everyone is like
by the way the baby keeps crying like
it's like yeah yeah
they do that they do that to make you
feel worse
about your circumstances
um
i think we'll probably wrap it up soon
but
yeah the
the casting is so good especially with
the
the
older jewish people there's so many and
i feel like
as you shot in new york or around new
york i feel like at a certain point if
you're like watching shows like you see
every like older jewish actor pop up in
a couple of things like oh it's outside
on broad city whatever like nypd blue
whatever um but these were jews i've
never seen before
um tell me about the casting process
we had uh
i well i'm like now some of them i'm
like i wonder what i would never looked
at their resumes much but um we had an
amazing casting geller uh casting
director named kate galler and
she pulled from
uh
mostly the theater community i guess um
and jewish actors she knew um and
yeah they populated the rest of the
roles other than sort of the principal
cast which we just sent offers to and
the ones who said yes said yes um
and they were in the movie and were such
troopers and um
just it was so like it was definitely
the lowest budget they've ever all
worked on um and the most uncomfortable
they've been but they were all very nice
um
uh but yeah we we had an amazing sort of
ensemble of of other
um jewish actors who've been in like new
york theater for so long and had so many
stories like of all like and they all
like knew each other and they were like
talking about like gossip from like 30
years ago like it was like fresh
it was crazy it was like what is that
what is that like um
it's like people go away in the summer
to do plays
it's called it's like
what is it summer's summer stock there
was like summer stock talk
and i was like this is the like spiciest
like gossip i've ever heard
yeah i also want to say that one of um
uh the actors sandra james uh who plays
maureen who's shorter and has curly hair
and is in the back seat with rachel and
um
molly at the end unfortunately uh she
she passed away a couple weeks ago so
um just wanted to honor her she was so
good and honestly the oldest one on set
and like was always so funny just so
funny and um
really sweet and had a dry sense of
humor and yeah she was just the best so
anyway shout out to sandra shout out to
sandra
um
well cool
it did is this the right timing do you
guys want to go home or do you want to
talk more
i don't know um
who's gonna are you guys gonna vote yes
for this
movie good
that's that's what we like to hear
young oh wait there's there's one more
question i wanted to ask
um if you if you want to
um there's a lot of big big kind of like
issues in the movie there's you know the
the sex work and there's the the
cheating and the bisexuality but you
never kind of like
go too hard for any of them or make them
the point um which i found to be
quite refreshing and because so often
you see these like issues talked about
as like so head-on and like we're going
to like tackle
sex work and end like
this stigma forever but like this came
to it from so many angles not
necessarily even all positive
um
and so can you talk about like was that
a a decision you made to kind of
not fall back on the tropes of any one
of the quote-unquote like
issues that were in the movie
yeah well thank you um i feel like we
were trying to walk the line um for a
few things i think that at least when it
comes to like seeing bisexual movies or
queer movies like and i think a lot of
people feel this way no matter what
their identity is like i'm tired of
seeing movies where the conflict is
about their identity um and
just want to see more stuff where
they're just existing with that identity
and the issue is about something else um
and i think that's how i sort of try to
approach her sexuality and the fact that
she's a sex worker and
you know other things going on um
because
like someone suggested like why doesn't
you know why why shouldn't what what if
it's revealed to the whole family that
she's a sex worker and then she has to
like you know defend herself and it's
like this is what i love and i was like
because that's not really what the
movie's about
and i i
um
yeah i don't know i think that i didn't
want to make something that was like
being bi is amazing and being a sex
worker is so fun and it's all great but
at the same time i didn't want to make
something that was like
being a sex worker is the most
depressing you know
sad thing in the world and also being
bias a curse and no one will ever
understand
being
it is a biased but
but you didn't want to address that
really
show both i think it was like
what we really were caring about was
like
not putting anything too hard on it like
just being like the way that it is in
real life like both all of those things
like where it's like there's nuance and
there's different layers and like also
like for sex work it's like she's
clearly like one really specific example
and it's like
then we're not like we're not making a
blanket statement we're being like this
is one example
of someone doing sex work and what it's
like and like
um yeah i feel like that was really
important to us
i i thought it uh played very well and i
was as appreciative thank you that was
portrayed
um
do you want to quickly talk about like
what you guys got going on next any are
you guys working on anything together
anything separate are you guys still
friends did you like have a huge falling
out after this movie did it destroy your
lives
huge beef um
our plans are
to have dinner after this um
should do you want to say
we're working on i'll say the thing and
then you say the blog line because you
do it really well
um
we are working on this movie that we
started writing actually after we
finished the short film of shiva baby um
and it's a very different tone it's very
like campy
horny out there comedy
um
yes
uh we here we go here we go uh it's
because
it's like a queer teen sex comedy it's
about like two nerdy queer girls who
start an underground fight club at their
high school to try to win over the
cheerleaders from the football players
um
uh it's much more in rachel's style of
humor and like when i talk about like
rachel pulling out the planner and being
like okay so this is what you're going
to deliver to me for shiva baby each
week each week we were also working on i
did stuff too is what
i know
it was
send me the thing you know every week
we'd meet up and do something on bottoms
which is this movie and then also i'd it
would be give me a deadline to like show
her something for shiva but yeah so it's
been a long time coming so hopefully we
get to make that next cool sounds great
and i hope to see it soon
thank you for making this beautiful film
thank you for doing this of course thank
you thank you so much thank you for
coming
and yeah um i don't just like vote yes
to everything
regarding them all right bye
[Music]